bienvenue dans paléo news l'émission qui
fait des news avec du vieux au programme
de cette émission des dinos qui voit
rouge des tortues souterraine des
nouvelles de néandertal est un dinosaure
aux rayons x
on commence par six baies roses aux
russes un nouveau venu dans la course au
plus gros dinosaures cyber aux eaux
russes est le petit surnom donné à un
dinosaure sauropode vieux de cent
millions d'années et découvert en
sibérie
ce serait à dinosaures proche de
titanosaures sud américain et du titane
aux réformes eux et au look us avec qui
il partage un arrangement en étoile des
vertèbres du bassin la fouille dure
depuis 2008 et n'est pas encore fini
mais les résultats préliminaires
viennent d'être annoncés en grande pompe
sibir horus mesurerait jusqu'à 20 m et
pèserait entre 50 et 70 tonnes faisant
de lui un sérieux concurrent à ses
cousins sud américain toujours du côté
des dinosaures on continue avec une
étude des espèces actuelles d'oiseaux de
crocodiles et de tortues qui suggère que
les pigments permettant de voir la
couleur rouge serait apparu chez
l'ancêtre commun des arts queloz rien
c'est-à-dire l'ancêtre commun aux
archosaures et aux tortues auparavant
cette hypothèse avait été écartée
puisque on pensait que les tortues et
les oiseaux étaient beaucoup plus
éloigné du point de vue phylogénétique
néanmoins les toutes dernières analyses
basées sur l'adn et les fossiles
confirme bien un lien de parenté et 3 si
cette hypothèse s'avère vrai alors les
tortues les dinosaures et leurs
descendants les oiseaux auraient tous eu
la capacité de voir le rouge qu'en dise
qu'elle aurait disparu chez les
crocodiles
cette nouvelle fait écho aux nombreux
fossiles ayant montré la prépondérance
de la couleur rouge dans le plumage des
dinosaures et puisqu'on parle d'art
queloz oriens parlons maintenant de
notorious qui du haut de ses 2 160
millions d'années était déjà connue pour
être la plus vieille tortue au monde ses
côtes large mais non fusionner en
carapace et la présence d'ouverture 10
abside chez les juvéniles en font une
espèce structurellement intermédiaire
entre reptiles tortue moderne
en plus de cela une étude vient de
montrer que douteuse aux russes
n'étaient pas aquatique
contrairement à de nombreuses espèces de
tortues actuelle mais préférer la vie
sous terre à l'appui de cette hypothèse
les auteurs pointent du doigt de
nombreuses adaptations à la vie
souterraine comme la robustesse de ses
membres qui lui permettait de creuser ou
la petite taille de ses yeux cette vie
ensevelie expliquerait l'origine des
nombreuses caractéristiques mystérieuse
des tortues actuelle
comme la perte des fausses dit abside à
l'instar d'autres reptiles fouisseurs
comme les ans fils ben la carapace quant
à elle serait apparue non pas à des fins
de protection comme on pourrait le
croire mais pour assurer plus de
stabilité lors du creusement des
galeries restons enfin dans les galeries
et les grottes avec la chaîne youtube de
universcience qui nous rappelle les plus
récentes découvertes faites à propos de
l'homme de néandertal sa biologie sa
génétique ainsi que les structures en
cercles de la grotte de bruniquel dans
deux vidéos courtes et accessible à tous
les liens apparaissent ici et seront
dans la description c'est que du bon la
curiosité de cette émission c'est la
découverte quasi simultanées de deux
fossiles de dauphin apparenté au dauphin
des rivières chinois actuels aussi
appelé dauphin du gange le platiniste à
la vraie surprise vient du fait que ces
fossiles proviennent non pas de chine
mais d'australie et d'alaska
respectivement ce qui pour une espèce
d'eau douce ne pouvant pas traverser les
étendues d'eau salée en reviendrait pour
nous à découvrir des fossiles
d'hominidés sur la lune
cela montre s'il en était besoin que
l'histoire évolutive des cétacés d'eau
douce est encore très loin d'avoir livré
tous ses secrets dans la rubrique
vintage aujourd'hui nous revenons en
1940 l'objet vintage de cette émission
c'est mais nato terium le squelette
presque entier d'un petit primate
découvert avec l'empreinte de ses poils
dans un village de l'allier mena dont il
tient son nom il fut découvert en 1940
dans des dépôts formé par d'anciennes
cendres volcaniques de plus de 50
millions d'années ce qui fait de lui le
plus vieux primates jamais retrouvé en
france et certainement le plus ancien
d'europe
il est plus vieux même que le célèbre
squelette de ida son homologue allemand
avec qui il partage son état de
conservation exceptionnel après que son
découvreur louis python est décédé suite
à sa déportation durant la seconde
guerre mondiale mais nato terium à
susciter l'intérêt des plus grands noms
de la paléoprimatologie de la deuxième
moitié du 20e siècle
simpson russell ou bien encore green jeu
riche aujourd'hui mais nato terium a été
renommé plaisir d'applis et sont fausses
il pique toujours au vif la curiosité
des chercheurs notamment au muséum
d'histoire naturelle de paris
le coup de gueule de cette émission
c'est celui de la société géologique de
france et du collectif pour le futur du
site de grignon concernant les menaces
qui pèsent sur le domaine de grignon
dans les yvelines et sur sa célèbre
fallu nière la fal une fière de green
est en effet célèbre pour sa plage
fossilisés ayant livré des milliers de
fossiles en tous genres représentant
d'une des plus riches faune jamais
extraites des roches daté du lutétien
certaines coquilles bien que vieille de
quarante cinq millions d'années révèle
encore leurs couleurs sous lumière
ultraviolette
le site s'était retrouvé menacé par un
rachat par le psg afin de construire un
nouveau centre d'entraînement pour ces
footballeur une pétition avait recueilli
25 mille signataires et semblait avoir
définitivement fait passer l'envié au
club de foot de construire un stade par
dessus la fa lumière mais dernièrement
un nouveau retournement a fait rebondir
la faire si ce n'est pas le psg qui
rachète le domaine alors ce serait
l'état du qatar lui même bien que la fa
lumières ne soient plus menacées par ce
nouveau projet les défenseurs du site
redoutent qu'il ne s'agisse d'une
manoeuvre afin de faire repasser le
projet original dans un futur proche les
articles et les liens pour en savoir
plus sur cette controverse sont dans la
description de cette vidéo
l'invité de l'émission aujourd'hui c'est
la paléontologue sud-africaine qui
mitent shuttle qui récemment passé en
france au synchrotron de grenoble afin
de passer aux rayons x un magnifique
squelette du dinosaure en it is qu'un
hétéro d'auto aux russes elle nous
explique dans quelles circonstances elle
et son équipe en sont venus à passer un
fossile comme celui là dans un
accélérateur de particules comme le
synchrotron et quelles sont les
informations qu'ils espèrent tirer de ce
scam
alors on a été au synchrotron il ya deux
raisons s'il ya deux autres façons de
d'étudier un spécimen
la première c'est donc de préparer un
spécimen de préparer tous les os mais
avec ce tas qui comme on l'appelle ce
spécimen en particulier les eaux étaient
trop petits trop fragile et le sédiment
ils étaient trop dures donc on pouvait
pas faire ça de matières de manière
manuelle
ensuite on a essayé de le scanner au
micro ct a vite mais il y avait trop de
d'inclusion métallique ce qui fait que
quand on regarde les scans y des grosses
taches lumineuses qui en fait obscures
les eaux donc le synchrotron permet de
retravailler ces scans pour éliminer
c'est cet intrus mineurs et aussi le
contraste entre les os et le sédiment
n'était pas suffisant que pour faire une
reconstruction avec le micro ct et la
phase de contraste au synchrotron permet
de bien délimiter les zones denses et
moi et héros tantôt douce est un des
plus petits dinosaures herbivores
en général les animaux qui ont ce genre
de dentition ont des dents de
remplacement des sondes on n'a pas
encore trouvé dans les taureaux deux
autres sont complets regarder dans le
remplacement aussi le l'avantagent du
micro ct mais aussi du synchrotron c'est
pouvoir reconstruire les eaux qu'on peut
pas voir sur le spécimen comme la boîte
crânienne
on peut aussi reconstruire le cerveau et
l'oreille interne et en est une des
choses les plus intéressantes avec ce
spécimen en particulier c'est qu'il a
des côtes ventrale ski dans les oiseaux
a aidé à la respiration donc bien de
voir qu'elles sont comment est-ce que
c'est co2 ventrale interagissent entre
elles et avec le reste du squelette et
il ya aussi le la cheville parce qu'être
une façon de marcher à ces
particulièrement qu'on pourrait mieux
comprendre la mort folle morphologie de
sashimi l'info de dernière minute celle
annonce de la découverte dans le montana
d'un nouveau spécimen de tyrannosaurus
rex
le squelette serait complet à 20% et le
crâne mesurerait 1 m 20
ce spécimen devrait finir exposé au
musée de burke qui a mené les fouilles
conjointement avec l'université de
washington
les fouilles devraient se terminer en
ce deuxième pas les oignons se termine
merci de l'avoir suivi toutes les infos
et les liens vers les actifs sont dans
la description
abonnez vous pour ne rien manquer
d'anciens à très bientôt